today in America there is 1.7 trillion
dollars of student debts
every year there are 20 million students
going through college one day somebody
has to pay
and so
this is a problem that is not only for
this generation who's borrowing the
money this is a problem for every single
generation our goal the mission of math
is to tear down all Financial barriers
to opportunity to everyone
[Music]
I was born and raised in Tunisia I grew
up in Tunisia under a dictatorship at
that time I was very active when I was
young against the dictatorship
[Applause]
I got kicked out from my country when I
was 17 years old and went through all
this health
I grew up thinking that life doesn't
matter if it's not for the greater good
and for and for like living it with
dignity
how they explained dignity was the
access to socio-economic rights
[Music]
Moss has a set of financial features
that helps you with the biggest
financial problems you will face in your
first years of adulting
and one of the biggest problem you have
is how to afford higher education today
higher education is either paid by a
family or paid by your future
what is incredible in this country is
that
the cost of college is like flight
tickets
you can be sitting here paying 200 the
person next to you is paying 1 000 and
next person next to is paying zero and
so Moss's job is to make you the person
who's paying zero
[Music]
one of my goals is that not only we
solved people's problems but we also
solved the problem meaning that the way
Moss has been built makes it become how
it should work and not a fight against
how bad it is that's a big goal meaning
uh really inspiring social change in
terms of like accessing
opportunity for the 99 I knew I wanted
to build this I had no clue how I'm
gonna do it and I started convincing
people
your team will be the reason
the succeed or to fail
I am absurdly optimistic I really do
believe things can change I believe that
the future can be bright I'm someone
that wakes up happy uh in the morning
and so I think
I I always think about like the biggest
problems in a positive mindset and that
keeps me going
don't follow my steps follow yours
foreign